et
ce projet l'on peut on peut vraiment
comparer à une grande course de fond
olivier daigle est trop modeste pour
s'en vanter mais il a réussi tout un
exploit
celui de tenir tête à nulle autre que la
nasa
en 2008 déjà on avait des résultats qui
étaient qui était meilleur que ce que
obtenu
après nous le défi c'était de réussir à
rester toujours un peu en avance pour
garder notre avantage
dans cette course il y a eu des épreuves
en montagne en ballon et en laboratoire
et pour gagner ça prenait des alliés le
tour de france oui il ya une erreur
qu'ils acquittent à l'avant qui comme on
espère qu'ils gagnent mais il ya toute
l'équipe derrière qui qui en fait la
grande partie du travail c'est une
épreuve l'équipe
[Musique]
une équipe à qui la nasa a concédé la
victoire
il y aura une caméra conçue et fabriquée
au québec à bord du prochain grand
télescope spatial
c'est la question à laquelle on essaye
de répondre c'est ce qui est de la vie
sur une autre planète dans un autre
système planétaire plus loin
la routine de olivier daigle ces vélos
astro dodo son quotidien c'est
l'entreprise de caméras scientifique
qu'il a fondé avec marie-eve ducharme
ensemble ils ont réussi à se tailler une
place à bord du futur télescope spatial
robben qui sera dans la même lignée que
cobourne qui a capté des images
spectaculaires de notre univers
et james webb qui bientôt vont scruter
les origines robben va notamment
s'intéresser aux exo planètes qui
tournent autour des toiles à des
distances inimaginable le défi c'est de
capter leur lumière sans être éblouis
par l'étoile on a une boule lumineuse
qui qui me crachent la lumière il faut
rester à avoir quelque chose qui sont
visés 500 milliards de fois plus faible
à côté c'est c'est un énorme défi
technologique
et pour le relever la nasa a mise sur
ces caméras qui sont les plus sensibles
du monde
c'est une invention qu'il fait mûrir
depuis 20 ans ça y rend l'esprit comme
il le dit sur le circuit gilles
villeneuve
parce qu'avant de faire partie d'une
mission spatiale il y avait des étapes à
franchir la nasa parle de niveau de
maturité technologique il premier des
neuf c'est avoir une bonne idée le
niveau 1 c'est à peu près au niveau des
lits des wii
est réalisable mais d'avoir une donc on
savait que ce type de détecteurs existe
et que ce type de caméra là on voulait
l'appliquer à la surprise et
c'est au mont mégantic qu'il a pu tester
son idée découverte l'avait accompagné à
l'époque sa caméra fonctionne comme
n'importe quel autre quand la lumière
frappe le capteur ça arrache des
électrons il faut ensuite déplacé puis
les compter pour avoir une image mais à
chaque étape on peut générer d'autres
électrons des parasites qui brouille
l'image c'est ce qu'on appelle le bruit
et l'idée d' olivier daigle c'était de
modifier l'électronique des caméras pour
réduire le bruit on appelle ça du bruit
parce que c'est comme si on essaie
d'avoir une conversation plus qu'un
marteau-piqueur à côté on est capable
d'entendre la conversation mais on va
perdre des monts des choses comme ça si
on enlève le marteau piqueur si on
réussit à ne plus avoir ce bruit la
balle on est capable d'avoir beaucoup
plus de subtilité dans dans ce qu'on
veut entendre
les tests ont été concluants sa caméra
peut distinguer la moindre particule de
lumière ce genre de performance dont le
télescope ou romaine aura besoin
avec le mont mégantic son idée grain au
troisième niveau de maturité
mais pour aller plus haut des choses se
corsent bonjour le défi en fait de faire
ses preuves
c'est facile de faire ses preuves sur
terre mais de démontrer qu on a une
solution qui peut fonctionner aussi dans
l'espace mais alors il faut aller dans
l'espace power pour la france qui est
plus compliqué le compromis ça a été
d'aller à mi-chemin dans la haute
atmosphère
l'université laval développer un
télescope pour photographier des
exoplanètes autour des toiles voisine
avec bien sûr une caméra ultra sensible
c'était mission d'exoplanètes
prototype mais mais le but était de
faire ce que l'on mène fait mais en plus
petit c'était sénou premier pas on
imagine l'exoplanète
et comme dans le télescope romaine on a
utilisé ce qu'on appelle un coronographe
cauvin est grave c'est vraiment comme
qu'ils ont mais note notre main devant
devant le soleil pour pour pour le
cachet pour voir ce qu'il y avait autour
c'est exactement le même principe mais
un peu plus raffiné
la plateforme contenant télescope a pris
le chemin de timmins en ontario son
aventure en ballons stratosphériques a
été pleine de rebondissements et
d'imprévus mais elle a confirmé qu à des
dizaines de kilomètres d'altitude aux
portes de l'espace la caméra fonctionne
toujours c'est un pas de géant dans
l'échelle de maturité technologique
on aimerait dire que c'est un sommet du
rite et numéro six mais c'était pas
encore exactement l'exacte environnement
spatial mais c'était je pense pour
plusieurs une démonstration suffisante
pour dire que
s'arrêter ça avait fonctionné dans
l'espace donc s'arrêter un l'atteinte
d'une grossesse
ce sera suffisant en tout cas pour
convaincre la nasa parce qu'elle essaie
de faire la même chose de son côté mais
n'arrivent pas aux mêmes performances
la nasa invite donc à bord du télescope
romaine c'est pas juste une fantaisie
que
[Musique]
qu'ils aient besoin de ce qu'on a
développé pour les ambitieux mais c'est
un contrat beaucoup trop complexe pour
sa petite entreprise de montréal c'était
absolument nécessaire de s'associer avec
une compagnie qui avait déjà l'expertisé
et les étages spatiale en fait d'avoir
livré des des instruments de cette
qualité-là avait des agences spatiales
comme la nasa ou l'agent spécial
japonaise par exemple ce partenaire et à
québec l'été dernier c'était une étape
clé et tant qu'à y aller il a fait la
route à vélo
abb c'est une multinationale de sang
mais l'employé mais la perle rare c'est
frédéric grandmont et son équipe c'est
vraiment quelque chose venait qu'on a
ici à québec le sait pas un pôle de
spatiale à québec mais notre groupe a
émergé de travaux puis a suivi un
parcours qui a fait en sorte qu'on est
là bien aujourd'hui puis sur un projet
comme le télescope romane c'est vraiment
le nec plus ultra si on veut
mais ça vient avec une foule d'exigence
sur la façon de s'habiller mais surtout
sur qui peut aller à quel endroit
parce que mine de rien ce conte est
aujourd'hui c'est une des caméras qui va
se retrouver dans l'espace c'est le bébé
d'olivier daigle qui ouvre enfin les
yeux pour la première fois son image on
voit bien la cible et continue la
luminosité on voit qu'on est capable
d'arriver en régime où on peut voir les
photos individuelles donc ça fonctionne
ça fonctionne comme ça de vrai et c'est
loin d'être banal parce qu'il a fallu
réinventer sa caméra
l'électronique qu'on utilise sur terre
est trop fragile pour aller dans
l'espace les radiations peuvent
endommager les circuits il faut des
pièces à prouver pour l'espace qui sont
plus robustes parce que le télescope
romaine sera quatre fois plus loin que
la lune est donc impossible à réparer si
ça plante mais tout le 3.6 millions de
dollars que vaut être mise à mal ces
problèmes le donc s'est appliqué à
chacun des maillons puis souvent dans un
un système informatique mais tout est
important donc on met le paquet partout
ça coûte très cher et des maillons il y
en a presque à l'infini il faut que le
télescope plus s'orienter prendre des
images mais envoyé sur terre et générer
de l'électricité pour chaque petite
pièce la nasa et pose une foule de
contraintes
on a plusieurs budget à respecter un
budget monétaire bien sûr mais mais mais
tous calculs donc on a un budget en
puissance on a un budget en mars on a un
budget en volume et le budget alloué
pour le volume c'est cette petite boîte
or l'électronique repensé avec l'aide
d'un bébé aurait pris trop de place la
touche finale ou presque ça a été de
plier l'électronique en sandwich une
étape pour le moins délicate
fin janvier abb a expédié sa précieuse
cargaison la nasa va mettre des années à
assembler les différents morceaux du
casse-tête et c'est une fois dans
l'espace que l'idée d' olivier daigle va
atteindre le niveau 7 parce que robben
ce n'est pas la fin de l'histoire
l'objectif c'est de montrer qu'avec la
lumière des exoplanètes on peut
découvrir ce qui se cache dans
l'atmosphère des meilleurs candidats
pour la vie aura fort à parier que si on
voit de la vapeur d'eau waouh ça soit un
candidat qui devient extrêmement
excitant pour la suite je pense qu'il ya
certaines découvertes qu'on va faire qui
vont augmenter niveau d'excitation dans
le domaine scientifique pour penser à
des missions puis à les observer ses
candidats lors avec des instruments
beaucoup plus évoluée et ça olivier
daigle aussi en rêve c'est la dernière
étape pour atteindre le niveau 9 celui
d'une technologie qui n'a plus rien à
prouver mais surtout parce qu'avec des
instruments encore plus puissant sa
caméra permettrait d'étudier des planète
jumelle de la terre
toutes les technologies qui vont avoir
été développé pour sa sont celles qui
sont nécessaires en fait pour je
développe un télescope plus gros qui va
permettre d'aller voir une terre autour
d'un autre oeil
c'est ce que ça prend si on veut un jour
être en mesure de répondre à la question
est ce qu'il ya de la vie ailleurs dans
l'univers
c'est probablement la question la plus
universelle de tout et il aimerait bien
y apporter sa modeste contribution
[Musique]